foreign
[Music]
briefing it's Friday May 12th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
imagine you buy a product you see on
social media a beautiful piece of
jewelry or a great kitchen tool maybe
the perfect shoe organizer but when it
arrives it's not at all like the picture
or product description that's if it
arrives at all these kinds of scams are
happening more and more so much so that
in March the Federal Trade Commission
asked major social media companies
including Tick Tock and meta to tell
them how they vet the advertisers on
their sites our family and Tech
columnist Julie jargon has been talking
to victims and looking into what's
behind this kind of fraud she joins me
now so Julie can you walk us through how
these scams work yeah a lot of the
online scams that start on social media
begin with an ad on say tick tock or
Instagram often for a product that is
very low priced and promising that low
price for a limited time
so people will try to order clothes or
home goods and often what they get is
not what they ordered if they get
anything at all can you tell me some
examples of the people who've been
affected by this yeah so we spoke with a
woman who was scrolling through Tick
Tock and she saw an ad for some shoe
organizing boxes you guys I got scammed
from Tick Tock ads so bad let me just
show you they were these clear plastic
containers that could be stacked and she
ordered them but they it took several
weeks for them to arrive and when her
package finally came there were no shoe
boxes inside the package just contained
a large plastic bag and she wasn't the
only one scammed by this ad there were
several other people that posted Tick
Tock videos saying that they were
scammed in the same way by the same ad
so that was just Longoria whose video we
played a bit of there was she able to
get her money back or get the product
that she actually wanted she was not
able to reach the company that she
purchased the so-called boxes from she
was able to get her money back because
she charged it on her apple card so she
went to the credit card and they
refunded her money but a lot of times
people you know if they don't pay with
credit card they don't get their money
back I also spoke with a woman who was
trying to buy a PlayStation on Facebook
Marketplace and she never got the
PlayStation and the mistake she made was
she paid through Facebook messenger and
she used metapay which is Facebook's
payment system but the payment was tied
to her debit card and sometimes it can
be difficult to get refunds for
fraudulent items if you don't use a
credit card and you only use a debit
card Julie usually when we're talking
about you online scam we're talking
about older people being affected who
maybe don't have as much knowledge about
the technology or the signs of
fraudsters but this is different these
are younger adults who are being
targeted so what's happening here why
are these younger people falling for
these scams well some people I talked to
mentioned that younger people you know
are used to buying things online it's it
feels normal and comfortable to them and
so they do it a lot more often and
they're more trusting and so that can be
part of the problem and the fraudsters
Really they go to the places where they
know their victims are going to be so
for older adults a lot of the scams
begin over the phone but if they're
looking for younger people they're going
to where younger people are which is
social media how bad is this situation
the reported monetary losses while on an
individual level aren't that high in
aggregate they they've grown to more
than 1.2 billion dollars last year and
that is a huge increase from 2017 when
the reported losses from these social
media scams amounted to 42 million
dollars so it's gotten to a sizable
enough amount for the Federal Trade
Commission to take notice and the FTC
recently issued orders to all of the
major social media companies asking for
information on how they vet the
advertisers on their sites you mentioned
that the in individual losses from a lot
of these scams are small are the
fraudsters just trying to get a lot of
people to fall for them to make money or
is there something else going on here
there's usually a bigger picture going
on where a lot of these amounts are
fairly small and they might mean a lot
to an individual but that's not really
the whole play here people who study
online fraud say that these scammers are
usually part of it organized criminal
Enterprise where they're really trying
to steal data more so than making money
from these small purchases so the
scammers will you know get your credit
card information and in turn quickly buy
gift cards or cryptocurrency with it or
sell the credit card data and names and
addresses on the dark web as a way to
make money if somebody wants to make
sure that they don't fall for one of
these scams but they do still shop
online and shop via social media is
there a way they can protect themselves
yeah there are a lot of ways that you
can protect yourself the number one
thing is if a deal seems too good to be
true it probably is so maybe avoid that
altogether if you see you know some
really great price for a product that
normally would cost a lot more you know
maybe raise the red flags about that but
the first thing really is you know
Google the company or the product a lot
of fraudulent products have already been
reviewed by other people
um on blogs on other forums like Reddit
and so you know just Google the name of
the product and most likely you'll get a
lot of hits another good practice is
instead of tapping on an ad and
purchasing directly through the ad on
social media open a new tab go to the
you know advertisers website see if the
website looks legitimate see if they
have a return policy and what that is
and see if there are multiple ways to
contact a business yes
that's our family in Tech columnist
Julie jargon and that's it for Tech news
briefing this week tnb's producer is
Julie Chang we had production assistants
from Jess Jupiter our supervising
producer is Melanie Roy and our
executive producer is Chris sinsley I'm
your host Zoe Thomas thanks for
listening and have a great weekend
[Music]
foreign